you know a gold iPhone is already kind
of a flex but have you ever wanted to
flex so hard it doesn't even make
financial sense anymore all right
here's a new phone this is the iPhone 11
Pro Sol Arius zenith buy caviar
[Music]
all right what's up guys I'm kid Bhd
here shout to everyone else on family
tech support duty during holidays I feel
you
so this there's literally nothing I can
say about this one that's useful to a
normal person this is purely just a
showcase of a fun and ridiculous
iPhone 11 Pro Mod because you really
just don't get to see something like
this every day
so this boutique this small company out
of Russia called caviar they've reached
out and they wanted to know if I wanted
to check this thing out it said would
you like to check it out
I said okay and then they flew someone
here to hand-deliver it so what exactly
is this this is a Space Gray iPhone 11
pro with the glass back replaced by a
massive mechanical clock structure
plated and covered in 24 karat gold and
exactly a hundred and thirty seven
diamonds it's ridiculous and actually
the ridiculousness starts from the
unboxing experience so after you get
past the included pair of microfiber
gloves and a cloth sleeve you get to the
phone box and the phone itself is in
this custom black and gold box
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so the peel was just as satisfying
as any normal iPhone and then for all
the accessories we'll blow it there's
another section of this custom box with
some paperwork including a certificate
and a serial number and a one-of-one
certification and then you have three
black boxes with your caviar accessories
first box is a USBC charger in the box
of an iPhone with a fast charger in the
box so you could its I guess you have to
spend a hundred thousand bucks on an
iPhone to finally get a fast charger in
the box and a second box is a lightning
cable and a couple of smaller things
including a custom gold-plated shark
shaped SIM card removal tool this golden
rod thing that we'll get into in a
second and then this third box is a
completely custom pair of matte black
air pods pro and a painted case with
painted logo and painted air pods
complete with the gold caviar logo that
took me off-guard that's actually pretty
impressive Wow okay so the accessory
bundle is really legit I was impressed
with that but that's not what we're here
for the main attraction is clearly the
phone first thing you'll notice and this
is not a joke this is super serious this
phone is incredibly heavy as soon as you
pick it up you'll notice this I put it
on a scale against a normal gold iPhone
11 pro the caviar phone weighs more than
twice as much 434 grams that's more than
two Galaxy Note 10.1 at the weight of
the one gold caviar phone so yeah it's
heavy in the hand it's thick too which
you can obviously see and then of course
there are tons and tons of details to
admire the lines the concentric circles
the engravings that diamonds all over it
it is absolutely nuts but it's all still
connected to a regular iPhone 11 Pro it
does have a pre-installed pretty low res
cavy
our wallpaper and the region is set to
Russia but other than that the
functionality is exactly the same the
great camera the great battery life the
whole thing I mean you know what an
iPhone is although I guess you don't
have wireless charging anymore
you're gonna lose that and then you
might have also noticed the text on both
sides on one side is the name-brand and
you're limited edition number one of one
which is so sick and then on the other
side you get a little more info it's an
iPhone 11 Pro it's 24 karat gold it's
got diamonds and it's a caviar phone so
what was that rod thing from before the
thing in the unboxing well the clock on
the back of this phone did you even
notice that the clock the clock on the
back of this phone is a fully functional
mechanical watch instrument thing
because of course it is so you get this
gold-plated rod in the box with the
logos printed on the caps and you can
unscrew it to reveal a hex tool and it
turns out this hex tool is what you use
to wind up the watch at the beginning of
each week on the corner here you can use
that to wind up the spring mechanism and
that gets it going and it just keeps
running all right actually looked it up
it's called a terbium apparently I'm
probably saying that wrong who will be
you but if you want to learn more about
them yourself you can just read the
Wikipedia page for that word I'll link
that down below if you want to have your
mind blown a bit but now you have a
working mechanical watch complication on
the back of your hundred thousand dollar
phone it clicks and ticks constantly and
you can hear it all the time especially
if you have your phone up to your ear to
make a phone call now I don't actually
want to put my SIM card in this Russian
phone to test it here if you can hear
the audible ticking through a phone call
but yet trust me you can hear it okay I
also noticed there's a glass screen
protector pre-installed to really
protect your investment I personally
almost never use these but there you go
it's on the phone and yeah if you go
spec one of these out on their site
right now you can have a similar one
made this one as SPECT is a hundred and
one thousand five hundred ninety dollars
and if you go up to the iPhone 11 pro
max since it's bigger it's much more
expensive because there's more gold and
just for the hell of it spec it up to
half a terabyte that's one hundred
twenty one thousand two hundred eighty
dollars but also limited edition
one of one so that's kind of sick I
couldn't eat that I was gonna drop it so
what why why does this exist why does
anything like this exist because you've
seen like those other random insert
luxury item here plated in gold costs
ten times what it should you've seen
that right the answer is again kind of
like the others just because they can
and and there's a small group of people
who will appreciate the customized
mastery of the mechanical engineering
that goes into a watch face like this
I mean think of the whole watch world
matter of fact luckily on the last
episode of the waveform podcast shout
out to it if you want to check out our
new podcast it is also linked below
we spoke to kevin o'leary aka mr.
wonderful on Shark Tank and I was just
chatting with him for a bit and at a
certain point we noticed I was wearing
an Apple watch Series 5 and he was
wearing an $80,000 collector's item one
of one watch with a special red band and
we talked about it you know the other
day I looked I was looking at this watch
and a woman beside me who I didn't know
said what time is it I said I have no
idea she said you just looked at your
watch I said that is nothing - at the
time I'm appreciating the art the
mastery of making this piece which is
one of ten in the world and it just
brings a tear to my eye and I love to
look at it yeah I have no idea what time
it is I don't care yeah so for that
person with a penchant for collecting
stuff and appreciation for the
mechanical engineering going on here I
could totally see that incredibly
wealthy person getting this phone
reaching in their pocket to pull it out
and just staring at it I mean sure
there's technically a clock on the back
but are you really reading that maybe
just turn the phone over and see the
time with the digital clock on the front
but go right back to enjoying the crazy
design on the back and that's it to be
clear I don't think this is a great idea
for most people it's a pizza of text
still it's kind of like how that Apple
watch edition gold version never really
took off and Apple eventually
discontinued because there's a new one
next year but hey if you gotta flex this
hard just start a conversation I guess
that's a hell of a conversation man so
that's pretty much it this is the
opposite of the tech that I normally
play with where we're like hey should
you buy this should you not but I figure
this is an opportunity I probably
we will never get again to hold $100,000
phone like this so I figured I'd share
that with you guys right back to the
stuff we typically talk about in the
upcoming videos and again shout out to
the waveform podcast down below we're on
Episode twelve already coming out on
Friday I think it's been pretty fun
either way thanks for watching donate to
team trees if you haven't already by the
end of the year talk to you guys the
next one peace okay so that was clearly
a video about something extremely
expensive that you should probably never
buy but you know it's not extremely
expensive that you probably should buy
this sponsor to this video which is Nord
VPN so just having a VPN in general is
great and it's useful and I've explained
it before in previous videos but
protecting your data online is very
important but also just selfishly the
ability to be able to check to see if a
website looks differently to people in
Russia for example than it does in your
home country using a VPN and the site
will never know that that's what you're
doing another useful feature so Nord VPN
is having a holiday sale right now and
you can see that at Nord VPN comm /mk
VPN or if you want to just use promo
code MK VPN that would get you a
three-year plan at 81% off plus two
amazing gifts for these holidays which
are four additional months for free and
the Nord Pass password manager app which
is $195 value so feel free to check that
out at the link below and again thanks
for nord VPN for sponsoring this video